hi everyone this is Jerry this is a
video covering McHale tall's last chess
game it was a blitz game and he was
playing the white pieces versus Garry
Kasparov tall was very ill at the time
and he supposedly snuck away from his
hospital bed room in order to play this
game
he was so ill that just days after this
game was played on June 28 1992 mikhail
tall passed away at the age of 55 this
game was quite brief lasting only 17
moves and it doesn't end with some
flashy checkmate or resignation or draw
by mutual agreement but rather black
ends up losing on time for this the game
really doesn't have a whole lot of
instructional value but instead I think
this acts more so along the lines of a
good piece of chess history so as the
game went what we have is tall opening
up with E for Kasparov responding c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight f3 development
d6
Bishop b5 check signaling the Moscow or
Rasul mo variation 97 and pond d4
signaling the open Sicilian Knight f6
development with an attack on the e4
pawn and white just castles offering
this efore pawn in exchange for possibly
some play along this efile black
declines this instead makes the move
pawn to h6 attacking the bishop
we have Bishop takes Knight Knight takes
bishop in white just continuing with
development Knight to c3 black follows
suit with pawn to e6 you can regard this
as a developing move because it's
helping the f8 bishop develop Bishop g5
development with an attack on the Queen
and black just gets out of the way and
plays Queen to c7 rook to e1 this move
is actually contemplating an eventual
sacrifice by placing it opposite the
King pawn takes pawn Knight takes pawn
and now we have Knight to e5 a
centralizing move pawn to f4 trying to
chase away the knight and black actually
ignores this threat and instead makes
the move pawn to h6 and in between move
attacking the bishop the bishop retreats
and now we have another in-between move
pawn to g5 attacking the bishop once
again ignore ignoring the threat on the
e5 Knight this sequence of moves this h6
coupled with g5 its main intention is to
create a hole on the e5 square by making
this pawn on f4 either move forward or
capture ePHI will ultimately be a whole
and black will then be able to pivot on
that square with pieces at later points
in the game so from here what we have
our series of exchanges on takes Knight
takes bishop pawn takes pawn Bishop
takes pawn and now a typical tall move
Knight to d5 a nice a typical tall
because he's regarded as the greatest
attacking player the game has ever seen
in fittingly in his very last game he
ends up sacrificing some piece in this
case the knight on d5 black accepts this
pawn takes knight in pawn takes pawn
discovered check and after King to f8 we
have Queen to f3 and black ends up
losing on time and this acting as McHale
towels last chess game for those of you
who are not watching this on YouTube you
can view this game by going to
youtube.com slash chess Network and for
those of you that are watching this on
youtube I've posted a link in the
sidebar
where you can actually view these two
players actually playing this game
through more specifically if you watch
closely the first three moves made by
each player you can see their hand
movements correspond with those moves
more specifically the moves efore c5
Knight f3 d6
Bishop b5 and Knight to d7 can be seen
so I've provided that for you and you
can check it out if you'd like that's
all for now bye
you